ừ ừ
anh alo chào bạn
Ừ ông
Ê con kia mốt không khác và nhỉ
thì các bạn đợi mình chị mình đang ngồi
chữa lại kìa ra phải ngồi làm lại cái
bài hôm trước mà Mình nợ các bạn Cái vụ
mà chưa câu câu sau cuối áp đấy
mình làm có phải Gần ra rồi nhưng mà có
về chồng hơi đau đầu để mà ngồi giải
thích cho các bạn
Em làm phải vừa làm vừa màu
em coi giả trách khối D
Anh sắp đến bản chất nó là
khi tắt bếp bản chất nó là delete và
Asus Nếu các bạn nhớ nhưng mà Bởi vì
Ừ cái này nó là cần
I I love chỉ delete những cái
bộ phim các bạn nhớ cái câu hôm trước
không ạ Các bạn nhiều về câu hôm trước
là có lớp và sinh viên do ngồi còn chỗ
trống đâu ạ thì mình sẽ phải kiểu kiểm
tra xem
lá
cây xuống chỗ chấm của alo alo đang thấy
mình khỏi xác hơn remix alo thì mình sẽ
phải kiểm tra xem cái chỗ trống của lớp
đấy có thỏa mãn hay không thì mình mới
được kiểu cập nhật Sinh viên vào trong
cái lớp đấy đúng không ạ
Em làm theo cách Anh hơi bị ở vẫn
em vẫn còn hơi sổ Thật ra không Tối ưu
lắm là mình mình đếm số lượng sinh viên
cập nhật kiểu đồng giả sử sinh viên đồng
loạt đổi
từ nhỏ
anh alo
mô hình chính xác là người mà vẫn nhau ở
xa
ở bệnh viện tí xem có vấn đề gì không
anh alo
anh alo alo
từ nhỏ
anh alo alo alo alo hai đùi to chưa
ờ ờ
Xin chào bạn để rút cái dây mic của mình
ra chứ
để mà dùng Thành nó hơi bị
Ừ địt
Ờ Ờ
mình Nó lặn gì nhé thì hôm trước là các
bạn nhớ cái vụ bài tập hôm trước nó là
lớp với sinh viên thì cái lớp nó có số
lỗ trồng nóng hoặc
mình mình khung trước mình còn Nộ Các
bạn về cái vụ là làm việc update mà bếp
này còn ăn bếp nhiều sinh viên cùng 1
lúc thì mình mình làm theo cách theo
dạng là kiểu mình sẽ đến em cái lớp mà
xinh toàn một rất nhiều sinh viên cùng
chuyển chẳng hạn ví dụ ra Xơ ra lớp A
sinh viên học chán quá đồng loạt đổi
phải năm sáu bạn sang lớp B nhưng lớp B
chỉ còn có mỗi 4 chỗ rồi chẳng hạn thì
thực ra thì thì sẽ không không đổi được
đúng không ạ Ừ thì mình sẽ phải làm như
thế nào là vừa rồi mình cũng nói thế thì
các bạn sẽ hình dung được làm đến đến
xem số lượng chuyển từ lớp A đúng đoạn
sau đó thì mình sẽ lấy số lượng trống ở
lớp B sau đó đi mình so sánh để để mà
kiểu mình xem là một số lỗi chồng có
thỏa mãn hay không ạ Nếu có thì mình
chuyến giả là mình phải xóa xóa dữ liệu
trong lớp cũ này và Asus và trong lớp
mới
thì mình phải xóa trước đã Bởi vì bởi vì
sao Bởi vì mã sinh viên nó là khóa chính
thế nên là nếu mà trường hợp mà các bạn
in xuất trước của mới Delete thì nó sẽ
báo lỗi vì mã sinh viên nó bị lặp lại
đầy ngoạn
ờ ờ
điện áp mình sẽ phải đi lễ trước kê
ạ sau đó mình nhìn sốt nóng lạnh
nhưng ở đây trong trường hợp việc là
số chống thỏa mãn có chỗ trống Không
không thỏa mãn Vì Sao Đó Ngoại Cỡ cháu
không thỏa mãn thì mình phải giữ nguyên
thế thôi thế nên là cách làm ở đây sẽ là
mình sẽ chỉ cập nhật những cái thang và
thỏa mãn không ạ Một là mình sẽ tạm biệt
đến giống như hồi trưa mình làm nhưng mà
cái cách đấy nó bị thủ công nữa cả là
một chị làm cho một sinh viên thôi đúng
ạ Còn bây giờ làm cho nhiều sinh viên
thì cú pháp của có lệnh là phức tạp hơn
nhiều
Ừ thì mình mới làm được cái vụ đi Lết
với Insert em bây giờ còn cả vụ
cập nhật
vì số lượng trống của lớp mới lớp cũ nữa
thì cái gì à
à à
ai cũng làm được thôi như mình đang làm
Giờ đây mình sẽ thử đây cốt của mỗi
Delete vì sợ đây mình sẽ giải thích lại
từ đầu cho các bạn về cái vụ này mình sẽ
xóa đi Nếu thế thì cái đầu video này nó
sẽ đau đầu đấy mình các bạn thông cảm
nhé đầu với Dao nó sẽ hơi bị xóa một tí
này
ngay từ đầu video đã hơi bị choáng cho
bạn rồi Mình thì cũng mới ngủ dậy mình
đang choán chúng ta cũng cho anh
ở đầu tiên thì các bạn thấy ở đây mình
có đang có ba lớp nhé lớp 1 này có ba
đây mình sẽ rất rồi đấy ạ
à à
ở đây bữa cuối màn ngoạn chấp nhận nếu
mà mày ông mà cảm thấy choáng quá đi
thôi tao buồn cuối này thật là cũng là
mình mình đi hẳn nó chữa bài tập mà đúng
không ạ thì nó sẽ có cả chữa có dễ và có
khó thì và Tí học cho nó xin được cũng
rất là ngắn ngang
Nói chung B buổi cuối nên mấy ông có
thắc mắc gì về mình cần chuyên sâu thì
mới Ông hỏi thì tôi trả lời
Ừ ông ơi Hôm nay ở buổi cuối của kẻ
chuyên sao mày rồi buổi sau thì sẽ À
đúng rồi Mình cũng đang thắc mắc về cái
vụ là buổi sau thì mình đang định tính
là như này đó là bàn chất nếu mà mình
mình mà họ có ru mẹ kiểu để mà thi vấn
đáp có dù đấy thì cái cái cái câu hỏi
của mình thì có hỏi mình cho các bạn xem
lại cái mục câu hỏi nhé á
à à
đi câu hỏi thi vấn đáp này có hỏi của
mình được ra chỉ có những thế này thôi
đúng không ạ
em chưa kể là mình còn chọn ra đum các
bạn nữa và Nếu giả sử lớp học của mình
có hôm này on tận 50 60 Ông chẳng hạn
thì thực ra là
Ừ mình không định hỏi mỗi bạn một câu
đâu mình không bị thế đâu mình hỏi Mỗi
bạn phải hai ba câu gì gì đấy thậm chí
hỏi thêm một câu nâng cao nữa chẳng hạn
không còn năm trong nay còn nâng cao sẽ
không nằm trong này
thì à
sau khi khi khi mà kiểu hỏi như thế thì
các bạn khi anh sẽ nghe được đóng ngoặc
và biết câu trả lời rồi ra thì nó không
hay
Khi dòng họ Thế có lợi cho người đằng
sau không ạ Cái chuẩn ra đấy chuẩn Cái
đó là mình sẽ phải Nếu muốn chấm Mẹ thì
mình sẽ phải họ hỏi riêng từng bạn đóng
ngoặc nhưng mà và lẫn cả họ hỏi vẫn 60
ông DK thì mỗi ông mà mất Tận năm phút
thì sóng với ông trước ơi Không biết bao
giờ một tiếng nữa chỉ 12 ông rồi trở lại
thì mình mình nghĩ cách tốt nhất Nó là
thì mình sẽ chấp nhận là có nhiều bạn
không Này không không được hỏi về Mình
chưa ăn đâu mình sẽ chơi ngẫu nhiên mà
nó ngọn ai được vào trước thì mình có
danh sách trước mình sẽ ra Đun trong cái
danh sách đấy là chúng mình sẽ ra Đun
liên tục thì danh sách đấy để mà mình ạ
chủ đề mình hỏi ông ạ ờ
ý nghĩa mình sẽ không thể hỏi hết đủ
cả ngày chẳng hạn thế à
cho nó giống kiểu kiểm tra miệng thôi
ông ạ ngẫu nhiên Ngẫu nhiên Bạn ở đó
Ừ Tự nhiên tôi nhớ cái cái video Vlog
của JVevermind
nó sẽ có trường hợp mà
Ừ Ông anh nhìn nói thêm vào thôi
Ê thằng kia không bị gọi lên bảng nhưng
mà thằng khác thì lại nói đẹp quá rồi
Thằng kia được gọi lên bản kiểu Cái đấy
để em nó sẽ có hai trường hợp là như thế
trong buổi hôm đấy nghĩa là sẽ có những
ông mà cửa ngồi nghe người khác
khi
bị hỏi rồi thuốc cai việc mình không
được hỏi
thực tế là nói thế nhưng mà thực tế là
cái hôm đấy mà các bạn đã non vào buổi
hôm đấy thì chắc chắn là các bạn đều
muốn được hỏi hơn là kiểu
tốt hơn là kiểu
chỉ muốn ngồi nghe không ạ Nếu mà Nhưng
mà thực ra không sao bởi vì a Mình đã
mình sẽ hỏi cả ở những câu nữa để mà các
bạn tự xem người khác sẽ trả lời như nào
nhân dân chọn Thậm chí các bạn có thể
bình luận và xử thế
thì mình nghĩ thế các bạn thì ta có thể
bình có thể giúp mà có tròn Chat đấy nó
có chat theo kiểu đã chắt gửi trực tiếp
em gửi trực tiếp đến theo từ trôi câu
hỏi mà từ chối trả lời thì cũng được
thôi mình có đánh giá điểm ông từ chơi
tôi trông không nghĩa
có cái trò chat gửi trực tiếp tin nhắn
đến thế nên mấy ông lúc và tôi hỏi xong
mấy ông có thể ờ
Ê mày ông có thể gửi câu trả lời
Nhắn tin trực tiếp cho tôi tôi sẽ chấm
điểm cho mấy ông cũng được rồi ông ạ thế
cho công bằng vậy nhé
Ừ nhưng mà Nếu thế thì mới ông sẽ chọn
mấy câu dễ thêm gân lại khá như thế
Em ở chỗ nào cũng làng nhàng mà cái cái
zoom mà hỏi thi vấn đáp của thế ai cũng
nghe được ra mình thấy vẫn bằng nhằm
đề thi và đáp ở trường trường mình từng
dậy thì nó sẽ là hỏi riêng từng bạn thôi
mỗi bạn sẽ là ba câu mỗi câu 3 đĩa Vàm
Và nếu muốn 10 Điền không ạ thì mình
đừng nói thì sẽ chọn công ngoài lề một
có sao
ừ ừ
bài hát Đơn Giản trả lời thêm câu nữa ở
trong Đồng Nai Ngoại Ô
Ừ ok Nói chung là mình đang nghĩ là như
thế không biết được là các bạn có đề
xuất gì đó hay hơn không Nếu mà được thì
thì các bạn cứ đề xuất đúng không có mày
còn 30 ôm
Ừ ừ nếu mà hôm sau chỉ có 30 ông có khi
lại hay
Ai biết đâu lại có đủ thời gian để hỏi
tất cả mấy ông đúng không
khi tôi còn đang lo vụ cái vụ trở về sau
chấm đồ án mấy ông mấy ông ngồi đây tận
mấy trăm Chắc phải chia rồi ba bốn lần
chấm
Chiều mình thế mà kiểu có nhiều lớp quá
cũng phải chia ba bốn lần bảo vệ
từ
hôm nay xem đá bóng nhá Ok cũng được
không sao hôm nay buổi Chữa bài tập nó
không hẳn quan trọng lắm các bạn có thể
xem lại mà bây giờ mình còn chưa ngay cô
Sao ngay từ vừa vào nữa thì nên là
Ừ đúng rồi xong môn này thì ạ thứ năm
chuyển khoa học của web
à à
Ừ thôi bây giờ quay lại bài này nhá Bài
này thì đầu tiên ý đó là bây giờ mình cứ
làm như cô đơn giản trước bảo là mình sẽ
Giả sử các bạn thấy ở đây có lớp 1 có 3
sinh viên này chỗ cháu ngã ba này lớp 2
chỗ trống là một tất cả tí update Nếu mà
cập nhật thì chỉ được một sinh viên sang
lớp 2 thôi lớp 3 Giả sử lớp chọn này ạ
hết sự sinh viên thôi ông ạ
ở đây mình sẽ Delete ở đâu Mình sẽ lách
các bạn hình dung
ở đây này
cho các bạn thấy mình đã in xuất có hai
sinh viên rồi
anh Đợi mình tí mình đi lên form sinh
viên phát ký xét lại
ô hay bạn sinh viên cùng vào lớp 1 này
các bạn xem lại nhé
ô hay bạn sinh viên đang ở trong lớp một
chỗ trống bằng ba nó vẫn bằng 3 thôi bởi
vì mình chưa mình đang chưa làm cái vụ
về cập nhật lại chỗ trống khi mày rất
hay Delete nhưng mà bây giờ mình sẽ làm
truy cơ đấy và cập nhật lại sủa trống
khi mà update thì sẽ như thế nào để các
bạn thấy gia sư là chỗ trống này
ở ngã ba như này mình cần cập nhật cả
hai sinh viên này sang lớp thứ hai hạn
hay thuận trí lớp thứ 3 cả nặng thiếu
niên trước là nó không không có bạn sinh
viên là được phép xa chẳng hạn thế đúng
không ạ thì
à Nhưng cái quan trọng để mà hình dung
làm được cái vụ đấy rõ ràng các bạn đang
thấy đó là khi mà sinh viên đổi lớp thì
nó không quan trọng với cái lớp cũ của
thằng sinh viên đấy Đang ở lớp nào đúng
ạ Con trọng là lớp mà sinh viên này sẽ
nhảy nhảy ra nó không ạ là sự đổi sang
lớp thứ hai ạ updates sinh viên sẽ lớp
bạn lớp bằng hai ngủ anh ạ thì rõ ra các
bạn Hình dung là một là trong một trường
hợp là chỉ có một bạn được 7 xa và một
bạn còn lại không được sang hạn hết xuất
nóng lạnh hay là cả hai cùng khu vực xa
đấy Kiểu thế mình sẽ làm cho các thứ hai
nhưng mình nó nói nó cách Tới thực ra
vẫn đơn giản hơn và mình sẽ đến xem cái
lớp mà nó sẽ chuyển sang đó ông ạ Cái
lớp mà nó sẽ chuyển sang và sửa mình cập
nhật như này được ngọn bạn lớp bằng hai
như này thế bạn sẽ sẽ hình dung được đây
sẽ cách xa
for
đế thật này à ở dưới chiffon in such để
các bạn dễ hình dung nhé ạ
Em chào anh ạ
the best show me update này thế bạn sẽ
thấy hay bạn đang ở lớp thứ nhất sẽ đổi
đồng loạt trong lớp thứ hai đúng không ạ
thì cái vụ mà mình mình kiểm tra đây rồi
như mình đã nói thì mình không quan tâm
thì việc là bạn đấy Đang ở lớp cũng là
lớp nào đó bọn mình quan tâm đến lớp mới
thôi thì các bạn sẽ làm như sau và các
bạn sẽ phải đến đúng ạ cao đếm xem là số
sinh viên sang lớp thứ hai là bao nhiêu
đúng ạ xong nói kiểm tra lại cái số chỗ
trống của lớp thứ hai xem nó có lớn lớn
anh cái số rồi Chồng con lớn hơn hỏi ra
bằng bằng cái số lượng sinh viên để
Giang không đúng ạ thì ở đây mình sẽ xóa
phân lý lẽ thật đi À cái phần ý sức thụt
đầu đồng bọn mình sẽ đến lúc ạ Mình sẽ
có mã lớp này sau đó như cao xa chẳng
hạn
sống một mình sẽ rút Bike theo mã Love ý
là sẽ đến được chỗ chồng không ạ đếm số
lượng sinh viên sẽ chuyển sang đó ông ạ
số sinh viên sẽ chuyển em ạ
Đây mình sẽ thử nhé
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy là cái lớp mã
lớp ở đây bằng hai này sẽ có hai sinh
viên sẽ chuyển sang lớp này đúng ạ
37 thi
em gái cái trường hợp ở đây này thì mình
mình sẽ làm theo dạng
Ý là mình sẽ
Em nói cái cái cả cái này cả cái cái này
nó tính là một bản rồi Khi mà selec này
xong nó tính em một cái bàn cái bàn này
bạn nó không phải bàn tạm thời nó nói
chung là nó làm kiểu kiểu Nó là một cái
bảng có thể soi được Có thể nối xanh bản
khác được thì mình sẽ nối ra màng lớp và
sẽ lấy sổ lỗ trống sau đó đi so sánh chỗ
trống của cái lớp đấy rồi cái số sinh
viên sẽ truyền đối ngoại mình sẽ làm như
sau mình sẽ là selects như thế này một
cái gì đó sẽ biết sao em ạ ạ
form này lớp này sau đó thì mình sẽ trôi
cả cụ này ạ
anh
admin là tê nó lại ra em ạ on each ấm
bạn lớp bằng lớp chuẩn mã các ạ anh em
bị Trãi có xem nhé
Ai
Cập nhật này
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ xảy ra của mỗi lớp
thứ hai hiển thị theo thôi Và chỗ chồng
nó bằng một số sinh viên sẽ chuyển 200
trường hợp này các bạn thấy thực ra là
nhìn lần thế này thôi là đủ biết được là
không thể chuyển sang rồi đúng không ạ
Tại sao con này chuyển được xa bởi vì là
số sinh viên sẽ chuyển nó lớn nó sửa chỗ
trống rồi đúng ạ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
cách để mà mình không lấy ra được cái
lớp này bằng cour này số sinh viên sẽ
chuyển không ạ Mình thể y chấm số sinh
viên sẽ chuyển cho nó chắc đi ừ
à à
có phải nhỏ hơn hoặc bằng với lớp chấm
chỗ trống như thế này à
khi chạy thử nhé
ở đây mình up bếp này thì các bạn thấy
em nó sẽ không ra một cái gì cả đúng
không ạ Bởi vì trong trường hợp này thì
hai sinh viên cùng chuyển sang cái lớp
thứ hai là không được nhưng bây giờ giả
sử mình Các bạn nhớ mình có hai sinh
viên không ạ
à à
khi cả hai lớp đều phun Nếu đổi lớp cho
sinh một sinh viên sang lớp kia và một
sinh viên sang lớp này
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok Ok Đợi mình tí mình sẽ giải đáp câu
này của bạn thực ra là mình cũng đang
nghĩ bài toán được A khi mà chạy update
như này rất khó để mà mình
theo kiểu là mình à
anh có thể ghi mã lớp bằng bằng 1 so
ngồi mà lớp bằng hai cùng lúc như thế
nhớ thấy vẫn có thể ghi được vẫn phải
ghi được
Ừ Ok nhớ đợi mình sẽ giải dần dần dần đã
nhé á
Ừ tí bạn hỏi lại mình đây nhờ đây thì
trong trường hợp này Đầu tiên thì xem
lại nhé các bạn thấy em mình có hai sinh
viên không ạ Thì bây giờ mình giả sử
mình cập nhật mỗi Mà bạn sinh viên sang
lớp thứ 2 thì chắc chắn là có thể được
đóng lại đây mình sẽ thử đây
ở đó thì nó sẽ nghĩ ra chứng tỏ là nếu
mà cập nhật cả hai cùng một lúc này
không ra một cái lớp là thỏa mãn nó ngọn
cập nhật mỗi một bạn thì thì cái bạn đấy
hoàn toàn được phép sang lớp thứ hai
đúng không ạ
Ừ cái việc mà bạn đấy được xong lớp thứ
hai ấy thì cách để mình làm đó là mình
sẽ Các bạn thấy nãy giờ ở đây mình sẽ
chỉ có lấy được mã nốt rồi không lấy mã
sinh viên không ạ Mình sẽ mình sẽ làm
như sau mình sẽ rất là đấy mã lớp này
lớp chấm mã sản ạ lấy được mã lớp đúng
không ạ
A và mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ
sẽ saxophone in sự thật này ờ
a Where mã lớp này in
nhờ các cụ mày tới bây giờ bắt đầu Phước
ta rất dài nhìn thấy thú nhận là cái câu
này nó rất là dài cái câu này tức là sao
nghĩa sẽ lấy toàn bộ những
những cải có những sinh viên thì ý giúp
thì các bạn nhớ mà đó là mình mình sẽ đi
reddy vài giây xuất vào mà ngoại thì
mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ những cái sinh viên
có thể ít
và cái mã lớn nằm trong thời danh sách
lớp có thể có thể chuyển vào không ạ như
thế này
tự tay mình chạy thử nhé
Anh Đài Giả sử là trong trường hợp mình
lại trả lại cái này thiên nhiên các bạn
thấy chẳng ra gì cả của vì rõ ràng không
có sinh viên nào được phép chuyển bởi vì
cũng tận hai sinh viên thì cả hai sinh
viên không được chuyện ông ạ Còn nếu một
ông điều chuyển thôi giờ xử ông ấy mỗi
một ông đòi chuyện thì nó sẽ ra được như
thế này Thế đúng rồi đúng ạ thì các bạn
này nó dễ rồi bạn này nó sẽ chỉ đơn giản
là
Ừ cái cái tôm này
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là trong trường hợp
này thì bạn sinh viên này
cho dãy số tục à mình dậy cô cô sẽ đi
rồi mà bạn Choco CPU có buổi họp vô sinh
đấy
a a a
Ừ
thì mình mình mình sẽ mình sẽ Insert
được cái cái cái sinh viên này không ạ
Như mình đã nói nãy giờ mình đang làm
thì ra nó vẫn chưa đúng lắm theo kiểu là
mình cần phải đi led nó trước ạ đúng
không ạ mình phải delete nó đã phải xóa
nó đã trước khi in such Bởi vì bây giờ
giả sử mình sẽ đạt in search into sinh
viên này Đấy số ngồi selected for đến
nay các bạn nhớ việc Asus có thể kết hợp
với sơ lách không ạ nghĩa là mình mình
thay vì mình phải điền va luu các thử
thì mình sẽ lấy dữ liệu từ một đau đấy
mình truyền đầy đủ vào trong cái bàn
sinh viên để trong trường hợp như mình
đã nói đó là cột mã không tự động tăng
hình mới làm ở chỗ này đúng không ạ
khi
mình chạy thử thì có bạn chắc chắn là sẽ
thấy nó bị lỗi bởi vì à bây giờ mà mình
chạy như này thì nó bị bắt đi kết cái
cột mã này ba lô là một này à
chỉ có mình có lưu lại vào trong danh
sách phát playlist của trên kênh YouTube
các bạn và xem lại nhé à
ạ Bây giờ mình cần phải delete nó vào
cái vụ Delete nó với làm nhà này đi lết
ở đấy là mình cần
chỉ cần hình dung như sau là mình sẽ
phải xóa dữ liệu cũ là đương nhiên là
mình sẽ phải xóa từ bản delete để tật đó
ngọn Delete from sinh viên này
nhưng mình lại phải liên quan đến bạn
biết thật để biết được là thằng sinh
viên nào sẽ bị xóa
ở cái đoạn này nãy giờ mình đang sẽ lấy
chỉ lấy được sinh viên mà mình sẽ chuyển
sang lớp nào đúng ạ Chúng mình không
biết được là sinh viên nó đang ở nó đang
ở cũng là như thế nào đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ thì cách làm ở đây đó là Delete này
cũng phải do I Delete này nó sẽ cho về
bạn đi tật nó sẽ ra nhưng sao
mình sẽ đặt tên kể
sau khi mảnh cho ấy khi mà choi vừa đĩa
thật như thế này
on đĩa cực này chậm mã bằng Sinh viên
chấm mã
mới cơ bản hai cái này đều là bạn bạn
đến tận này non sinh viên nên bạn này
cũng đã bạn sinh viên thôi ông ạ và bạn
sinh viên thì hay hàn nối qua cột mã là
được đúng ạ
và nó đang báo lỗi ở đây vì à khi mà cho
lại thì đây tận hai bạn thì nó không
biết được là các bạn sẽ muốn đi nét bạn
bản nào thôi đúng ạ thì mình sẽ đặt tên
ở đây là mình sẽ chỉ biết hết bạn sinh
viên thôi các bạn sẽ ghi như thế này
Delete sinh viên trong có gọi đau não
dân Cái này nó là kiến thức mới này
chuyên sâu mà Bọn tôi sẽ nói cho mấy ông
mê kiến thức kiểu mới tí
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà delete như thế này
không thôi thì thì nó sẽ Delete thẳng
tất cả những bạn nào ở trong bạn Delete
biết thực đúng ạ Mà không có kiểm tra gì
cả kiểm tra ở đây là gì kiểm tra đây lại
như vừa rồi là phải kiểm tra những cái
bạn nó thỏa mãn kiếm việc và có thể ít
xước móng nhọn thì đây có một cách nữa
anh nhìn đoạn này mấy ông lại bay não
này mình Royal phát nữa
vào bảng Asus
vi
phạm Huệ instant trẻ mãi như thế này sau
đó thì mình lại webcam cả cụ như thế này
à
à à
Ê bà sân trường hợp này là insta trầm mã
lớp như thế này Tại sao phải làm cả cụm
như thế này vì như vừa rồi Các bạn thấy
là mình có kiểm tra về việc là bạn lớp
thỏa mãn thì mình mới cho
mình mới cho Insert để ngọn thì tương tự
như vừa rồi Như trong trường hợp này đó
là bạn lớp thỏa mãn thì mình mới cho
Delete để mà mình đi xuất chứ đúng ạ Còn
không thì mình đi led làm gì không ạ đây
tôi sẽ chạy thử cho mấy ông xe
xe tải
ở trong cốc có vẻ rất dài nhưng mà mình
giải thích từng đoạn từng đoạn đó mấy
các bạn rồi mà bọn các bạn có thể thấy
Cốt nó dài và nó mới Nhưng mà mình sẽ
thích từ cái rồi nên là các bạn hiểu là
được con đề mà Cốt lại được đoạn này thì
chắc là
Ừ chắc là phải vài năm nữa rồi Tôi khẳng
định là tôi cũng phải vừa mới ngồi mò
mới ra màn không ạ nhưng tôi không trách
mà Mấy ông là mấy ông nhìn nợ này chung
tròn qua
đây đây mình thử update nhá không áp bếp
được gì này
ở đây đây mình thử select either ở cuối
mình sẽ access for love và select from
sinh viên đi
để các bạn xem lại xem nó có thay đổi dữ
liệu gì không nhá thì bạn sẽ dễ hình
dung
đây update này thì các bạn phải là hai
sinh viên vẫn nằm trong lớp một chả gì
thay đổi ngoại bây giờ mình cập nhật mỗi
một bạn mã bằng một bạn Long này sẽ được
ưu tiên xanh web này các bạn tuổi như
không Này cập nhật này
ở đó đúng thế cứ chạy ngon rồi đúng ạ
Nhưng ở đây như mình đã nói ra nó không
chỉ đơn giản đến nay không ạ à
Ừ
Ừ nhưng mà vài năm nữa mới không làm
được đoạn này thì lương gì nô rồi tôi
đơn đang nghìn đô mà nó ngoạn chưa bây
giờ mày ông mới học
học xong cái khóa học MBA trên sâu nghe
thời gian Cũng lâu đấy nhưng mà mong
lương nghìn đô luôn thì thực ra thì như
thế thì tôi lương vậy đến chục nghìn đô
tôi mới dậy được mấy ông theo kiểu để mà
được lương nhìn ô ấy
Ừ Ok bệnh như mình đã nói thì cái vụ Cập
nhật lại
cái xuống chỗ trống rỗng lặng thì mình
sẽ hơi bị đau não một tí bởi vì mình
cũng lại phải kiểm tra xem là
em kiểm tra lại đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ thế có một cái Bí quyết ở đây nó dễ
hơn một tí đó là thực ra là các bạn sẽ
chỉ cần đã
ừ ừ
Tôi đếm đếm cái lại đến một phát nữa
ngọn lặng đến phát nữa là
mình mình thực ra mình cũng chưa làm đâu
Mình đang thử nghĩ đó là mình sẽ đến
phát nữa xem số sinh viên thỏa mãn
Ừ đúng ạ sau mình cập nhật thôi
nào để bị xem nhé
số đầu tiên này mình phải cập nhật cho
lớp cũ trước đi mình cập nhật cho lớp cũ
sẽ copy được cái đoạn này
anh
ở đây mình cứ hẹn
Ừ tao lấy xe mà cá cái đoạn này để mà
kiểm tra in xuất thỏa mãn này thì bắt
buộc phải rồi cái đoạn này rồi này rồi
đến rất thật để mà mình biết được là
các bạn lớp là như thế nào này đoạn này
sẽ lấy được mạ lớp này
Ừ chắc sáng nó đã lấy được mạ lớp rồi
ở đội đầy là mã lớp nhé bạn lớp này
để lớp rồi
Ở đời mà lớp này về lớp này
Ừ thì đây mình sẽ có selex
Vì
sao for love
Ừ rồi với cả như này đi
khi đọc Tôi sẽ thử chạy cái này cho bé
ông xem nhé
à à nhưng mình cứ đi lấy hết đi á mình
đi lấy lại từ đầu này Tại sao phải đi
lấy lại từ đầu bởi vì cái bạn sinh viên
kia đổi sang lớp thứ hai rồi không ạ
mình đi Xếp mình sẽ đi xét lại này
ở xa lạ này
ở đó như này lúc đầu đang có ba lớp 2
sinh viên không ạ chú chạy này
à à
ở
tại mà tạm trú thích cái đoạn này đã
Costa fan kéo kéo chuột lằn chuột cũng
hỏi mày đấy
Ai Cập nhật này nếu trong trường hợp này
thì các bạn thấy xe lách chẳng ra gì cả
một vé như mình vẫn nói hai bạn cùng
không chuyển cho lớp với ai được hiển
thị này nó cũng không ra gì à
anh sai nhỉ
Ừ Chút tao dạo này bị sai đúng không ạ
Để xem ạ
lớp cho với hết tất
Ừ đúng rồi Nếu mà cho ai biết thì À thì
sẽ là lấy ra mã lớp bằng một đúng ạ
Ừ để mình xem nhé
khi sex
em
tự nhiên đoạn này mình sẽ bắt đầu đủ rồi
Nếu mà cho như thế này thì nó không đúng
này không thể nếu mà làm cho em trường
hợp như thế này thì khác khác gì bảo là
thằng sinh viên này nó vẫn ở lớp cũ bởi
rỡ ra cả lớp delete và lớp y z thực nó
bằng nhau thì nó đang ở lớp cũ rồi
xóa lại đi này
Ừ nhưng mà xóa Dạo này đi thì mình sẽ
nhà mình cần cấp
Đợi mình hình dung nhé Mình Dũng bài
toán đã nghĩ xem lại bài toàn đã
à à
a snack xe Ford
khi đói
ạ Bạn ấy đổi sang lớp thứ hai mất rồi à
ở Mỹ chống lại bài toán trà sửa hai bạn
một đổi sang Nếu đổi thành công đúng
không ạ
em đổi thành công thì mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ cập nhật lại chỗ trống cái
này phải - - cao đúng không ạ Và Cái này
sẽ là cộng với cái cao
ờ ờ
ý nghĩa là kiểu gì mình phải trôi bảo về
mà lấy được cái cao để cộng và
Ừ dạo này có khi là không phải phức tạp
với đoạn phải que
cũng quen như này
anh cũng gan nó sẽ lấy từ đoạn này đúng
rồi nó sẽ lại tự do này thôi
à à
I I I love lớp mã này
anh nóng rồi Đúng rồi cái này nó chỉ cần
nghĩa nay thôi Cho mã lớp
bộ phim sex update
of xét
số chỗ chấm a
à à
ở chỗ trống bằng chỗ trống ở
ở đầu tiên à cái này đi xuất thật tiền
anh cái cộng đi
số cộng với số xịn
chứ chứ chửi bởi vì đây là số sinh viên
sẽ chuyển sang mà nói - for nên anh
khi chạy thử nhé cái đoạn này mấy trẻ -
nhé mình chưa làm về cái vụ Cập nhật lại
cộng đâu
cô sinh viên này sang
lớp thứ hai mất rồi lại phải đi lên đấy
anh lặng im sót lại
em kiểm tra lại Ok này
Ừ nếu cập nhật như nay
Em à mình bỏ cái phần xà lách nè rồi
a snack lại ở dưới vậy chuyển xuống dưới
nhé
họ
đậu xanh à
à Không có gì xảy ra cả bọn Nếu mình cập
nhật kiểu nhà con nhớ cả cập nhật các cụ
ngày ra à
31 bạn chuyển sang
31 bạn chuyển sang vào - đúng không Đúng
rồi trong trường hợp này đúng rồi đúng ạ
và tương tự như thế mua vận chuyển sang
được thành công thì mình sẽ phải đi phải
Ừ cái quan trọng ở đây là bây giờ mình
Cập nhật lại số chỗ số sinh viên sẽ
chuyển từ bạn đến tất cơ
vừa rồi cho em ạ Nhưng xuất thật của nó
phải dễ rồi đúng ạ Bây giờ mình lại phải
làm bạn biết tất cơ Ừ để xem nhé số sinh
viên sẽ chưa
Khi mà mình vẫn phải kiểm tra Quan trọng
mình vẫn phải kiểm tra trong bảng Y rất
thật là
ở chỗ trống đầy thỏa mãn
Ừ chú phải mỗi roi bạn hết thật rồi cứ
thể cao rồi xóa đâu không ạ
gọi
điện xem cái đoạn đấy như thế nào
à à
Khi bữa nào update lớp thôi này rồi
Ừ cái này Nói chung nó lại chuyển sang
phải cậu không ạ Và cho đến cái đoạn này
để mà mình lấy được
ở đoạn này để mình lấy được là
Lê Đức Thọ mắn
em đau đầu nhỉ
em làm đến nay rồi mà vẫn còn không ra
được thì buồn lắm ông ạ Yêu Rất Thật này
ừ ừ
Làm sao để trẻ mình hình dung lại mình
bắt lại não đã nha à
ở đây nhớ trong trường hợp mà
cô sinh viên
Em cập nhật lại lớp
Ai Cập nhậtđại lợp khi mà à
ở lớp 1 này sẽ không được bên mình có
hai trường hợp 2 trường hợp xảy ra đi
là trường hợp
lớp 1 sẽ giữ nguyên
Khi nào khi mà
hai sinh viên đều đòi chuyện
sang lớp 2A
vì vì vì là ở
một số chỗ chợ mới Nó rồi chỗ chấm lớp
hay không thỏa mãn
Ừ cái việc không thỏa mãn Tức là sao Tức
là
đếm số sinh viên chuyển
lớn hơn
một số chỗ chấm
của lớp 2
đây trường hợp 1
ở bảng trường hợp 2 thì lớp 1 sẽ thay
đổi hoặc là
và thay đổi nó thay đổi như thế nào nó
số chỗ trống
số trừ bằng hoặc trừ bằng số sinh viên
chưa
khi mà kiểu đương nhiên là ngược lại này
thôi không ạ
em thấy mình đang kiểu giả code và mã mã
sản nó như thế này
ở cái trường hợp một này ba mình sẽ đến
mình đến được rồi đúng không ạ
Anh đến rồi và mình sẽ lấy từ bạn đến
tất
ở điểm số sinh viên sẽ chuyện này
Ừ ok rồi này
Ừ nhưng mà Android Dạo này không đúng
nữa này
để
thực hiện đổi đại lý thật nhạc
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà chỉ đơn giản đổi nó đi
tất như thế này nhé Đợi mình tí mình
giải thích bạn có vẻ mình ra được vấn đề
rồi là sư mình độ nóng như thế này đúng
rồi nó là như thế này Thế mình không còn
quay lại này nữa ra xử lý thì không cần
que vì rõ ràng mình sẽ đến tất thì mình
không cần kiểm tra cái gì cả và sự thế
đây mình chạy các bạn xem lại nhé lý về
da luôn đây rồi
Anh xóa đi này
anh đi xát lại
để tui thấy hợp mất công đoạn này vậy
ở đây đúng không ạ
Vì sao nói gì Tôi chạy lên Anh
ăn Tết
bố mẹ tôi cập nhật như thế này
chị xem nhé
anh đùa đúng không ạ Nhưng ở đây lại có
nhược điểm đó là cập nhật là được rồi
được rồi nhưng mà ở đây có nhược điểm đó
là nếu mà giả sử tôi cập nhật tôi lại
I delete đi lấy lại phát nữa đi
ở lại đây Delete Insert snack
ở đây
ở tuổi updat mỗi trường hợp như thế này
ăn thịt các bạn thế là thức a số sinh
viên nó vẫn sẽ bị nhảy A Gọi bởi vì mình
chưa kiểm tra điều kiện gì ở đây mình
chưa kiểm tra điều kiện gì đây thì bây
giờ mình chỉ cần kiểm tra điều kiện thôi
điều kiện đó đó là như thế nào Cái kiện
đó là khi mà cái á
ở cái trường hợp
ở lớp cái cái cái lốp à
có những điều tôi đã nói nó là trong
trường hợp mà
anh cứ lớp này sẽ thay đổi này đây
khi mà
ở lớp sẽ chuyển không ạ
Có đủ chỗ chấm cho sinh viên
Ừ từ lớp 1 xa nó
cây Susu cái cái lấy cái việc số sinh
viên từ lớp 1 xanh mà mình sẽ phải ở đây
này
ứng dụng
thì mình sẽ roi đi cái này vẫn phải cho
đi
cho instant
- Lexus
khi đi shopping
Vì
vậy tôi xem nhá vẫn phải do nghĩ rất
thật nhưng mà mình lấy cái rồi mình so
sánh cái việc à
ở lớp chấm Mã
I love chấm Xuống chỗ trống nó thỏa mãn
các điều kiện đấy thì mình mới cho chắc
tí mình như thế
đã có trường hợp nào mà dạng là kiểu bị
cập nhật
Ừ Ok mình mình cho tổng any where
có
khái niệm Where is it never make beat Ơ
a
Where Is this a
à à
a snack à
hôm nay
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ Để tôi gửi chạy thử với đoạn này xem
được không đã
Ừ thế để bà á
đề bài Chắc từ buổi trước rồi chứ không
không không phải không không không có đề
bài trên đâu vậy bài tục bữa trước rồi
xe đẩy Chữa bài tập mà chạy thành công
này
em đi lấy lại chồng không nhận tại vẫn
ơi cái liên khúc đi lấy thôi
đang đi nè
Ừ ok này
ừ ừ
I Delete Insert Gold
em ở cuối này cập nhật mỗi một trường
hợp
ô tô xe máy
anh vẫn thế đúng không ạ cập nhật như
nay
đi xe máy
một
số chỗ trống không tăng lên à
Ừ thế có gì đó Sai sai nữa rồi
ở bệnh viện mình thấy xem bạn đi
khi kiểm tra nếu mà đúng thì tăng
Ý Trời đúng vậy à lớp Hà nó lấy lớp ở
trên này
khi cài đặt tên lại như này đi
lời đi
à à
ở andros
nữ sát thủ chấm
anh Bởi vì có hai bạn lớp nhầm sang
thằng lớp ở dưới
ở lớp chấm Mã
Ừ cái wed axit này là sao là kiểm tra
xem mà cái này nó đúng nó thỏa mãn cả
cái cụm này nó ra được cái khoải trong
trường hợp này rõ ràng các cụ mày ra kết
quả mà
à À rồi Mình hiểu tại sao gần đây lại
đây rồi Cái cái này như mình up date
Ừ cái này
Em
ơi xem nhé
khi đun nóng rồi mình update - trước nên
thành ra nó bị nó như thế này bảo em
phải cộng cộng trước nhỉ
em gái mình phải cộng nữa
a fake phải cộng cho cái á
Ừ cái cái cái cái đoạn này là sao Là
mình lấy lại cái việc là lấy số cho lấy
sổ chỗ trống của cái thằng lớp thứ hai
đúng không ạ Các bạn nhớ họ là mình
chuyển sang lớp thứ hai mà không ạ nhưng
mà Bởi vì mình cái cái lỡ lỡ chạy cái
chùa trước thành ra cái lớp web này nó
thành không còn chỗ trống nào thế này
cái đoạn mà lúc mà mình mình mình cái
câu lệnh này mình lấy lại số chỗ chấm
của nó thì Hưng Yên chỗ trống Không
không thỏa mãn anh phải ra ở câu cộng
này nó không thỏa mãn này lại bơ mình
chạy lại được này à à
anh nghe được mày không tin thôi à
ở đầu tiên up date nhé
áp đây này không được chứ Toàn ai đúng
không Không khó không được không ạ Đó
bây giờ mình sẽ update hay bạn nhé đó
ngon chưa Alo Đấy Thế này thành công đó
ở cái đoạn này nó đúng kiểu rất là Lú
theo kiểu là thì mình sẽ phải
ở đoạn này tôi giải thích lại nhé đoạn
này thì ông mày mày ông ngoài việc là
nổi đến bạn đi rất thực để mà Cập nhật
lại cái số lượng sinh viên sẽ chuyển
không ạ Không ạ
Ừ thì chỉ đơn giản ạ nhưng mà mình sẽ
phải thêm cái điều kiện mình kiểm tra
xem việc là cái cái lớp lớp mới nó được
Insert chắc chắn nó được ý rất hay không
cái đoạn này tôi kiểm tra như thế đó là
sinh viên lớp mới chắc chắn được in soát
thì tôi mấy cái mới cho cập nhật như thế
này à
anh đúng không ạ Và và còn vụ ở dưới nữa
khi ngủ dưới này thật ra điều kiện động
tương tự thôi đó là
Ừ nếu mà sinh viên ở ở lớp
lớp mới có chỗ trống thì mình chỉ đơn
giản là mình cho - thôi nó không ạ
ê ê đê và chính lớp cũ thì so sánh ạ Để
chạy thử thôi này thử nha
ê ê đê vào lớp 1 Đi đúng ạ thì đặt bếp
vào lớp 1 nhé đội 2 sinh viên sang lớp 1
này
Ừ đúng rồi bởi vì rõ ràng có một sinh
viên Tuấn hiển nhiên đó là trong lớp 1
thôi đúng không ạ
anh không xa anh
Vì sao được
ạ bây giờ xử lý resort thẳng thêm hai
bạn nữa đi cho chắc à Ba bạn nữa đi
ờ ờ ờ bà này
Anh ở lớp thứ ba đi
và sau đó thì chuyển sang lớp 1 xem có
được không nhé vợ yêu thử nhé á
A5
có điều ở lớp thứ ba Ba bạn này ở lớp
thứ ba Các bạn xem nhé
33 Bạn ở lớp thứ ba đổi sang lớp thứ
nhất từ xem được nhé
anh tóc date
Ừ có gì đó Sai sai đấy
33 bạn sang lớp
em không được anh sợ không được nghỉ
ừ ừ
khi đến đoạn này nó bắt đầu chịu đấy
Anh xin lỗi nhờ có gì đó sai sai rồi
à à
cách chữa bài tập hôm nay giỏi phết của
mỗi câu sau rồi mới chữa mất cả buổi tối
ta không làm mất cả buổi tối những mất
gần một tiếng thôi
đã sửa code lập trình các bạn mất cả
ngày nó chuyện bình thường tôi từng mất
đến 2 tuần thậm chí đến tháng mà
cách
chữa cho mấy ông thì phải ông sợ mày ông
cậu thấy lâu quá nạn thôi tôi quen thôi
Tại sao đoạn này lại không chạy được
nghỉ đi em nhỉ
số điểm 3 Bạn ở lớp thứ ba này
khi đổi sang đất
ở chỗ trắng ở đây chắc sao thỏa mãn rồi
khi tôi bắt đầu Mệt quá
ở
đây tôi sẽ thử copy Đúng cái loại này
thôi này
cho phép bất cứ đoạn này sang bên này đã
từ
nãy giờ ra mình chị quanh còn đi quanh
còn lại mất câu này cái câu à
Ơ con này
Ừ
đúng rồi nếu nếu mà làm như này thì
chuẩn ra sổ chống bọn lớp thứ ba nó sẽ
tăng lên và chỗ trống của lớp 11 mà sẽ
giảm đi sẽ sao phone như này à
hỗ trợ tiền chạy mỗi câu này thôi đã xem
Tại sao nhé
ở không gian này
ừ
rồi rồi tôi hiểu tại sao rồi Cái cái
đoạn này Mình đến như thế này
ờ ờ cái đến như thế này là danh lấy cả
đến của cả sinh viên có sẵn trong lớp
này thành ra là đến như này thì nó là số
chỗ trống số chỗ chấm của
của là cái cái vụ đến đây này đây tao
cho mày không xem lại chỉ mỗi cái đến
này đâu nha
à à
khi xảy ra là
655 chứ nhỉ
35 bạn sinh viên mở rộng thì có hai bạn
đang ở sinh trong lớp này rồi đúng ạ
thành ra là tùy ở các bạn đã hình dung
các bạn đang hình dung và vừa nãy mình
cũng bị nhầm như thế đó là có 3 bạn
chuyển vào thì từ ra chỉ cập nhật mã lớp
cho ba bạn thôi nhưng mà không
Mình đã từng nói khi mình update bản
chất nó delete và in-shop tức à là nó
Tuyền nhìn như này trông có vẻ đó chị
chỉ cập nhật cho mỗi 3 bản ghi nhưng mà
không có cập nhật hết cho cả 5 bản ghi
đúng không ạ Cái đoạn này chuẩn đấy
chuẩn một là que mã lớp bằng ba như thế
này thì nó mới ra này như thế này cơ thì
nó mới ra được là thì có 3 bạn sinh viên
ở lớp thứ ba đội xanh lớp 11
Ừ nếu mà tôi mà giữ cái cốt này thì tôi
chỉ chạy được chưa mày thôi còn nếu mà
trường hợp như thế này là rõ ràng mà
mình sẽ phải khoe theo là mình sẽ thể
kiểm tra nữa thêm một lần nữa là mình
Nếu mình đến như thế này mình sẽ phải
đến là
mã số sinh viên số sinh viên
mà lớp đầy vẫn giữ nguyên vẫn giữ nguyên
xịn đối ngoại sau đây không còn ở số
sinh viên sẽ chuyển nữa đúng không ạ Nếu
mà mình theo trường hợp như này bởi rõ
ràng là số xinh đi sẽ chuyển năm ở đây
bằng sai nó phải là ba thôi mà đúng ạ
đúng không ạ Vì sẽ phải were theo cái
anh nói chung cũng đau rồi nói cho bạn
lại đau đầu thêm thì nữa là mình sẽ phải
kiểm tra kiểu những sinh viên đang ở
trong lớp cũ thì phải giữ nguyên nó
không đến không đếm và số sinh viên sẽ
chuyện chuẩn là như thế
Ừ nếu hiểu ý tôi mất
chắc cũng khi dung được mà đúng không
ừ ừ
ở đây đây đây để tôi thử
làm nhang cho ông nhé Where mã lớp này
not in không nằm trong đó
tuổi Tôi đoán chữ ông Toàn mấy ông sắp
thử in rồi nó tin cái thứ
mã love
for
instant age Thật chứ ạ
ở đó
xe chạy được
Mở hộp đêm này
em không ra ông ạ yêu đợi tí
ở army đếm là mình không muốn đến cái
thằng này thôi chứ không phải là mình
loại bỏ đi nhỉ quên đấy
Em không phải loại bỏ nó đi mà mình sẽ
đến
đợi tôi lại download rồi
a and affect - chứ không phải là When
not in it
Ừ
đúng rồi một câu một đống sắt như này sẽ
rất nặng sau quý các thứ đầu tiên là bản
chất là mình sẽ phải đến
cài đặt cấu hình dung lại nhé
ở bảng instant này để em nó sẽ ra năm
thằng này à
ăn đít
à À đấy thế Mình phải cho đúng rồi cho
bé thật này
gà con
à à
I
love nho đi
bạn lớp à
ăn
uống nghỉ
đợi tôi tí nhé à
à à
ừ ừ
ổ đĩa xoáy quá Thế thì chắc chắn xài quá
anh Cao
Cả hai vẫn say
các bạn này tôi bắt đầu bãi não ơi bạn
này là như tôi đã hình dung nhá như tôi
đang hình dung nó là mình sẽ phải loại
bỏ sinh viên đang ở lớp cũ là từ bảng ít
tức
khi mình không đến nó
Ừ tớ sao nó là quen nó tin
anh không đếm những cái sinh viên đang ở
trong nước cũ để tôi xem mà
a where
a mã lớp nếu mà nó tin như này không
đúng à
à à
xe tải mã mã sinh viên không nằm trong
lớp cũ và mới đúng
Ừ
đúng rồi
a snack mã formatted where
anh mãi Love =
I
install chấm mã lớp
Ừ đúng rồi phải đi này tôi ra được rồi
nó không được nghĩ tôi đủ
anh alo rồi chưa được chưa xong chưa
ở đó
để tôi
em sửa lại đoạn này cho mấy ông ạ
em nhóm Bình tĩnh nào
anh khó khăn lú một tí thỉnh thoảng hay
lui tí thôi ạ
à à
là
ngon rồi
anh cứ đoạn nào mà đến sinh viên chuyển
này
ở đoạn này
Dạo này không biết
các bạn ý dân tộc này thì biết rồi Dạo
này không biết làm gì anh nhỉ à
anh chạy đổi nó hạnh như thế này à
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ chắc được
Ê tụi bay nào rồi thì thôi kệ đây thôi
Sẽ có pin rồi
Em không biết được nó có chạy được không
đâu
à à
ừ ừ
ở tuổi cột dài thế
về cha gọi thử ca không không không nên
để dài như này mà mình nên làm bằng lập
trình ngôn ngữ lập trình nhưng nó sẽ dễ
hơn những kiểu trong phức tạp như thế
này
Em thử nhé ad
em có ngon không Alo
anh alo ai nói tôi lũ nào Alo đó
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ cập nhật bạn lớp bằng
3 này quay Mã
em nằm trong danh sách
Tức là sao nghĩa là mình sẽ đổi ba bạn
đầu sáng lỡ thứ ba bên nó ba chỗ trống
rồi ông ạ
ở đó được chưa nhóm kiện tôi nữa không
Alo Đúng không đổi
anh sang Mã lớp là hai của trả lại cho
sao nó không được lại nóng
ở đó không được đời mình đổi mỗi một bạn
mã bằng hai sang lớp thứ hai được không
từ đó đưa gối
anh nói chưa toàn bộ cốt rất dài ở trên
này mấy ông thích tìm hiểu về đọc lại
điều Ngoại Ô tô bay não quá à
à à
A discourse
có this code của nhóm mới không biết bạn
kia hỏi thế bạn ơi Kris của nhóm chưa
Ừ ok Bây giờ tôi xin phép
triệu mỗi người tập này Dạ con thôi Còn
bài tập cả chứ cả hôm ấy cái bồ nữa thôi
Anh xin lỗi các bạn nó hơi bị ra em tí
cho dù rõ ràng là trước đấy một tiếng
tôi đã ngồi chuẩn bị bà này đấy nhưng mà
tôi vẫn chưa Chuẩn bị xong tôi xin lỗi
anh không nhận rất chúng ta đúng ạ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ thôi không sao bạn nào chưa hiểu hay
các thứ Tạm Nói chung là tạm mất não nãy
giờ tạm bỏ qua điện mình xin phép chữa
nhạc chế ca bài nữa
anh chả lẽ không chữa cho các bạn
bột cuối mà nó bọn mình xin phép chữa
lại thật ra mấy ông có thể ngồi tua lại
video mà Để xem
mình xin phép chữa cho các bạn thế này
gần như là để cho như mình đã nói Thực
ra buổi này là buổi mình vừa cả đi đi
bốc nữa thông ca mình và cả đi Bắc nữa
và để chữa bài tập từ đây là phù hợp cho
việc các bạn xem lại hơn là xem trực
tiếp trên trực tiếp kể lại nó bị lú rồi
Gì Các bạn phải tua cũng được vân vân
phù hợp với việc xem lại hơn ừ
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ chữa cho các bạn thêm
câu này và sản xuất nữa
à À hồi có khi tôi dậy mày không cháy
rừng chữa trước đi để mẹ mày Ông cảm
thấy nãy giờ đau đầu quá mình nhảy xanh
thế chà sẽ dần trước cho nó dễ sau đó
thì tôi cũng sẽ chữa bài tập ở đây thôi
còn ai muốn ở lại xem phần bài tập chữa
nốt bài tập thì ở lại để không ạ Không
thì cứ tạm nghỉ tôi rồi có gì mình không
xem lại cái phần chợ mới tập được mà
nóng bạn Xem lại video sau Ok nhé Cái
chai cái sân nó là gì thì cha ra sân Nó
là kiểu dạng và khi mà có vấn đề về câu
truy vấn theo kiểu là bây giờ thì các
bạn có bạn lớp các bạn xóa xóa lớp đi
em
chụp màn hình câu quá dài chụp màn hình
luôn cái một cốc cốc cho mấy ông hai mấy
ông Thực ra là Cốc Cốc nó cũng chẳng lẽ
lại ý nghĩa gì lắm Tôi muốn mày ông xem
lại cả video này hiểu được cốt hơn thế
nên tôi mày không đầy cốt thường hay mệt
mấy bộ Hôm nay tôi không có đây mình
cuốn lại lên người ông xem mấy cô này nó
lúa đấy
Ờ Cái chai rất sần Nó là kiểu khi mà các
bạn xóa cái
anh xóa Giả sử Xóa bảng lớp khi mà đang
có sinh viên em đấy ạ Mà nó có ràng buộc
khóa ngoại thì nó sẽ cảnh báo lỗi cho
bởi vì nó ràng buộc những cảnh báo lỗi
hoặc là khi mà các bạn Insert vào
à mà nó có cái check nó kiểm tra nó cũng
bảo lỗi chẳng ạ
Ừ thì khi mà cái lỗi đấy nó không phải
lỗi Phúc cú pháp xin tắc là lỗi cú pháp
này nó sẽ lỗi về exception tất cả lỗi về
ngoại lệ khi mà đang chạy cốt không phải
Roku phát Chị ấy sắp chuẩn ở nó thì các
bạn sẽ có khái niệm troai cáp tất cả
chạy thử cái gì đó chai cáp nó sẽ dạng
như thế này thường khi Lập Trình Trái
cáp nó sẽ như này là khi thử cái gì đó ở
trong này đây một đoạn cốt các bạn không
ạ Và nếu mà lỗi thì nó sẽ chạy vào cái ở
trong cái thằng này
đây à Thử cố trong ngoài thử chạy cost
A B C không ạ Còn nếu mà lỗi thì sẽ
thường lại in ra
thông báo lỗi rằng ạ
thậm chí là mình sẽ
em chạy một đoạn khốc khác chạy đoạn
thuốc khác chẳng hạn thế khi
a cho xe xin nó nó áp dụng các quy tắc
trai cáp được chăm chăm nọ trong
Jonathan Tức là sao nghĩa là do sử là
các bạn đang Insert dữ liệu vào tận ba
bản em ạ Bạn A = B = C nhọn Nhưng mà nếu
mà lỗi 100 khi mà in xơ và bảng B 2 bảng
C nó lỗi các bạn muốn khôi phục lại tất
cả thay vì thì thay vì bởi vì nếu mà các
bạn nhớ là các bạn nếu mà bạn chạy độc
lập từng cái Côi sát như thế này bình
thường bình thường đấy các bạn chọn đồ
lập thì rõ ràng là các bạn lại không
không biết là
không không lấy lại được dữ liệu mà đã
lỡ rất là Bảng A bảng B dọn các bạn phải
cố sửa cái câu Y Z C thôi và thuận chẽ
không khóm à Delete được cái A và B đúng
không ạ
Ừ thì đây các bạn muốn Insert cả ba cái
cùng một lúc một trong ba cái lỗi thì
các bạn cần khôi phục lại dữ liệu cũ
đúng ạ bể mà các bạn sửa lại cho đúng
hết đã rồi một các bạn mới in-shop cả ba
cái thằng cùng lúc thì đây nó sẽ khái
niệm là con nít như thế này nghĩa là các
bạn sẽ đầu tiên à
anh đi tất cả các lệnh các bạn cần một
ghi sau đó thì con nít là đầy đồng loạt
tất cả câu lệnh đẩy lên cùng một lúc để
cùng chạy ở cùng lúc chứ không phải chạy
độc lập từng hàng một nữa và
Ừ nếu mà giờ xử sai chai cáp những mà
sai đúng ạ thì mình sẽ khái niệm robot
robot tất cả sao nó là quay lại cái quay
lại trước khi đẩy toàn bộ về đó ngày lên
đấy khái niệm low-pass là như thế các
bạn nếu chơi game thì các bạn sẽ biết
thêm khái niệm về xếp for nữa xếp thoi
là
là lưu lại tại một thời điểm nào đó
thường mấy ông kiểu trước khi đánh boss
mày ông cậu sợ là của mình mất hết điểm
số mình ở quay lại nếu mà Giả sử một vài
gây mấy nó sẽ là cả ông chết đi là ông
quay lại màn đầu tiên đấy ông không muốn
như thế ông sẽ lưu lại là ông đang ở màn
từ bao nhiêu mà từ bao nhiêu em ạ đang
đang như thế nào đấy là có khái niệm
support ông đương đại tại thời điểm đấy
ông ạ và cái vụ xếp Oy áp dụng ở trong
đây đó là các bạn có thể robot đến cái
Sếp tôi đấy như thế này
Anh đang nghe đây tên của support nhé
đấy
ở trẻ sơ sinh nó sẽ nhịn cú pháp của
chạy ra sân thì được gato có chi qua đây
mấy ông xem rồi nói begintransaction đấy
thì ra mấy ông thì copy để luôn mấy ông
dung này cậu ngay thôi
thử cái tội không có bài tập ở đấy lắm
mày đọc truyện này nó dễ dùng rồi
bigin Jackson tên gọi cho Sơn này xong
rồi đầu tiên bigin troai này Đấy xong
rồi thử chạy những cái câu truy vấn gì
đó đúng không ạ rồi Con Mít là để mà đầy
đồng loạt tất cả câu hỏi lên này xong
rồi Ăn chay này Bi rồi E này rồi cắt và
bị bắt nhớ là sự một trong đồng câu lệnh
này không chạy được là sử là bây giờ sự
là các bạn thấy là xóa sinh viên nó xóa
lớp đúng không ạ thì có phải rất ổn
nhưng giờ sự nếu xóa lớp trước Ừ thì nó
sẽ lỗi nếu là sự sinh viên ràng buộc về
lớp đó ngoại thì nó sẽ nhảy và thằng cát
như thế này và các bạn để in ra là không
xóa được em ạ sauropus Nếu propad đấy
thì nó sẽ khôi phục lại toàn bộ những
cái câu câu lệnh mà đã chạy ở trong việc
phân chai này đó
nghe thấy tôi nói ngang qua trái đất hơn
thế thôi Thực tế là ở công ty
của tôi thì tội không áp dụng cho sức
xuân này như tôi nói
chị cơ và code thường được áp dụng nhiều
nhất là các công ty in Bac thì hiển
nhiên được áp dụng rất nhiều bởi vì nó
liên quan việc cả câu truy vấn phải
nhanh nhưng mà
vì con trai xuân này không cho nó sướng
của SQL thì thường là mình đi vào trong
ạ trai cát ở trong ngôn ngữ lập trình
trước mình không tạo cái chân trước sân
nhé nhưng nhưng mà tôi vừa nói cái
sadboys cái xếp toy lại được áp dụng thì
Thoa được áp dụng
seaboard như tôi đã nói nó là lưu lại
như loại dữ liệu tại một thời điểm không
ạ thì các bạn cách để tạo khi suppose
thì đây nó sẽ chỉ cần ghi là support này
sau đặt tên nó support thì xe Ford sẽ
được sẽ được tạo này sau đó lấy các bạn
muốn một Robot Thì chỉ cần cho Bac tu
xong rồi tên một Spore là nó sẽ quay
khôi phục lại dữ liệu để người sẽ rồi
đấy thử cái này nó không hạn hay lắm Chị
áp dụng nên áp dụng kèm với Johnson Các
bạn thấy nó độc lập đúng các bạn thấy
vừa rồi nó chẳng có chai cáp gì đây cả
Anh đang độc lập
Ừ nhưng mà nó không phù hợp với việc là
các bạn kiểu chạy ví dụ là các bạn tự
nhiên hứng lên robot lại đến cái xe Ford
đó là đồng nghĩa việc và dữ liệu của bạn
trong thời gian từ cái sex boy đến đến
lúc mà các bạn robot bị mất hết đúng
không ạ thì không nên áp dụng vào đấy
lắm là nên kết hợp với Jonathan khi mặn
thử chạy cốt một cái đoạn khuôn nào đó
có vấn đề các bạn hãy dâu bác lại
Anh trừ khi là từ hôm qua giờ tự nhiên
có một đứa nào đó vào nghịch phá rằng ạ
Các bạn một robot lại đến sáng ngày hôm
qua đi mình mới ông hack ơi mẹ mày cơm
và phá thì mấy ông thưởng này supports
theo này thường ai thế thậm chứa nhiều
công ty lớn hơn thì nó là sẽ ko cho từng
do chẳng ạ Đấy thì nó sẽ robot lạ chả
Johnson này thì Nhưng mà như tôi đã nói
gì
Ê mấy ông khó không áp dụng khả năng
nhiều đâu
Ừ ok
ờ ờ
ạ bây giờ lại gọi lại chữa hay tóc
bài tập này thì cái code thì tôi sẽ bỏ
qua nhé
ông
cha để tôi thử làm cái này nhanh được
không
khoa học bổng để tôi thử nói chuyện với
anh anh Tuấn
về cái vụ là cái nồi một bên tay trợ nó
đó để mà kiếm học bổng cho mấy ông
Hà Anh Tuấn hiện không muốn làm hai cậu
dạng là ờ
áo kiểu
lợi nhuận lắm Hay các thứ thứ
các em à Để để tôi thử hỏi lại thầy hiệu
trưởng nhanh chứ tôi không có quyền
quyết định gì đây cả Chả lẽ tôi tự bỏ
tiền túi ra để trao học bổng em bé ông
tôi tôi chỉ đã tôi khẳng định được là
tôi đảm bảo trong béo người Cái đầu ra
với rất nhiều bên hỏi tôi về cậu nguồn
nhân lực các thứ thứ mà Bây giờ tôi bảo
rồi đấy trường nào cũng trường nào cũng
kiểu đào tạo nhưng mà có có đã bảo chất
lượng các thứ đâu thì tôi dậy thì ông
thì tôi hiển nhiên cho tôi biết mày ông
từng trình độ từng mấy ông như nào viết
hoa rồi
khi đôi khi mà em không cần nộp bài tập
đó tôi chỉ cần thấy mấy ông bình luận
như thế nào trộn thấy có có rồi Anh hiểu
qua được các chữ
ừ ừ
à à
hai nước cà phê ý tôi ở không phải một
tiền mà phần thưởng tuần thưởng thì Phần
thưởng là gì phần thưởng mua bằng tiền
mà nó không hay là mấy ông muốn chơi
kiểu phần thưởng theo cờ tôi tặng mái
tôn giấy khen in giấy khen thì ở thế kỷ
ngồi thiết kế là một cái giấy khen đúng
không Nếu mà quan trọng là nó không
đây không phải một công ty rồi thì nó
không có cái dấu nhận gì cả cho
Ừ ừ nếu người ông thích thì tôi chứ
Ừ thôi bảo bạn còn vẽ ra một cái kiểu
mẫu giấy khen một cái template đúng
không ạ Tôi sẽ điền tên với ông trên đấy
rồi vinh danh mấy ông nó đăng lên nhóm
này là vinh danh những cái sinh viên nào
đó
à Thế chưa Nếu vòng một có một cái tem
bếp nào đó mà không có cái giấu gì đó
xác thực ra là mấy ông cũng thể copy có
thể kiểu
em làm nhái Dương người tự điền tên mình
mới hết đấy kiểu cổ thế chồng mà không
hay là
anh ạ
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
à à
10 lời đúng là lời nói của di tru bây
giờ thì cũng có hiệu lực tương đối với
các doanh nghiệp đấy có có
anh em còn thấy khen thì chưa biết được
anh chưa có cái dấu gì xác nhận vẫn bị
làm nhái mà không ạ Làm nhái thì lại mất
danh tiếng anh ạ
ở Pháp Sư bé ngoan
Ok Thôi tạm Quay lại cái này một tí đó
là à
để cập nhật sản phẩm khi
à à
thế này để tôi thử làm nhé ạ
Ừ cái vụ cập nhật này ít ô cập nhật
không phải một update đâu nhiều bạn ở
đây bị nhầm việc mỗi update cập nhật ở
đây nó sẽ là cái sơ phải đi led ạ
anh
xóa điên address table nói cho bữa hôm
nay rất là dài tôi khẳng định lại buổi
hôm nay có thể lên đến 2 tiếng đấy bởi
vì tôi còn chữ bài tập này nữa Cái bộ
kho mã nghe tôi không trách mấy ông đều
mới ông thoát rồi
tra 50 này
tổng tài sản
flash cũng được cũng được và sức chứa
đi này trước chưa này chính là số lượng
của
số lượng có thể chứa được cái à
Khi
bữa cuối đó là nó phải cũng
không phải dài hơn một tí mà nó không ạ
mã tên số lượng
về số lượng
giá trị
A
và mã kho
mã có à
có ai trà sự có hai bạn như thế này tôi
sẽ in search bảng khó trước đi
Đây là một này
hoa Bọn ta này à
có tổng tài sản cho đang là không Nó
ngọn iPhone là không sức chứa được sự là
chưa được 10 thôi chẳng ạ và khó bê
xong ra sản mà nó không loại trừ được 20
Giáo sư Thế ông ạ Ừ tao như thế này và
bây giờ mình sẽ tạo sticker ờ
để
thêm sản phẩm à
Ừ cái vụ à bây giờ làm theo kiểu đơn
giản làm như còn đơn giản giống như cái
câu này thì nó lại liên quan đến việc là
ở after after
khi mà Apple đây
cho tôi sẽ dùng từ Ai Cập nhật đi gặp
mặt sản phẩm
có thể giải thích tại sao tôi là tên như
thế after
his skin II
khi con
sunfat ạ
ở đó là xa là mình sẽ
Ừ mình ở đây mình sẽ là lấy tổng tổng
tài sản là lấy từ thằng một như này
khi cài đặt mình mình ra sự bài toán đây
nhá sản phẩm đây nhá
Anh tên giá trị ngoạn giá trị Đây là năm
càng này số lượng là mười này số lượng
là một đi một chút đi ở đây cái bút đi
bút này
anh sex Nhật
em 10 cái này số lượng 32 này vào trong
kho thứ nhất này kho thứ nhất này giả sử
như thế này vào một cái là
anh bỏ đi
hay và khó thứ hai trở nặng như thế này
kia mí xuất như thế này thì rõ ràng là
mình sẽ phải cập nhật lại tổng tài sản
của cả hai kho đúng không ạ
khi cuộc kho thứ nhất thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là 5 Nhân 1 cộng với 10
mỹ nhân 21
ờ ờ thì rõ ràng ở các bạn thấy là cần
phải lấy tịch tổng đã lấy tổng đã xô
ngồi cập nhật cùng một lúc và trong cái
bảng
kho không ạ Đây mình cứ update kho đã
được ghi Accord không ạ Nhớ mình sẽ có
xét này tổng tài sản bằng tổng tài sản
cũ cộng với cái gì đúng ạ đề ra là
Insert thì chị là cộng thôi đúng không ạ
khi xếp cộng một cái gì bọn cộng với cái
tổng của việc mình tính toán như nào đó
đây đúng không ạ
Ừ thì đây cái tính toán thì mình sẽ mình
tặng
Vứt cái cốt này ra đây đã lại mình tính
toán thì mình sẽ cưới sẽ lách trước đây
đi đã mình sẽ là xà lách à
có giá trị
nhân với số lượng
không ạ from
East thực tế
em ạ chạy thử nhé
ừ ừ
xin lỗi
Anh Ở Đây Rồi nó 3
sau đó thì các bạn sẽ ra được nhưng mà ở
đây là mình muốn
họ đậu xanh đúng nhỉ 5x với
anh ở đây mình Kiều cái mã còi mã kho
là chị nhân với số lượng
mà tại sao lại đây Cái này á Cái này 40
này Ok cái 40
thì mình cứ điện Delete from sảnphẩm lại
phát nữa nhé đi xe máy in sẽ lại và đây
sẽ press enter
Ô kìa này
à
Vì sao lại phải lượn ơi
ở đó
ở đây
thì nó đang sắp xếp thôi bị loạn một thì
không có chậm được ạ Có chậm việc là mã
kho thì tổng tổng tiền tổng tài sản của
kho một khi máy in sơ và mới thì nó sẽ
là 25 đúng ạ Mình sẽ dựa qua đâu thì sẽ
giúp bye
mã kho thôi đúng ạ Và mình đây mình xăm
như thế này ass tổng tài sản mới ạ như
này khi chạy thử nhà
ở lại đi lấy đi này
I Insert Đà Nẵng
đó Ok chị ạ
Ừ cái này ra rồi được rồi không ạ thì
mình sẽ chỉ luôn ảnh cập nhật thôi
update kho này
khi
xét tổng tài sản cộng với tổng tài sản
mới
do I với
anh như thế mình sẽ có
forstall cho với
tất cả các cụ mày đúng ạ
thì mình sẽ đặt
các cụ này
lại lại thành một cái bạn mới thôi ông ạ
đi nè
à
on key chấm mã cos bằng kho chấm mã ạ
các bạn như thế này là được
khi chạy thử nhé
sự thành công này I Delete trước này
I Insert này
a
slack
select lại xem nhé
Vì
sao Ford
Ford Mazda cx6 form sản phẩm à
Ừ Ok chị ạ Đi
Ừ cái này là đang không phải lâu với cha
nên không có dấu nó Kệ đi Ok thì
ạ bây giờ
Ê bà làm cho cả Delete với update không
ạ Nhưng có một cách chữa hai này đó là
Ê mấy ông không hề biết được là có thể
after được nhiều thì cái như này đúng
lúc đúng ạ
đó thì này
em update nó cũng bản chất là delete và
Insert cho bạn niềm ạ
à à
sự thật hay đấy nó là đi Rex
để được đây này đây này Ừ cái này là
châu Á
số cũ đi sáng ạ
Thế là xong
khi chạy thử nhé
Hôm nay tôi đi lấy thẳng luôn đây
ba mẹ tôi đi hết hẳn luôn
á nhon âm
ừ ừ
ở buổi quấy mà nó Ngoại Tôi chỉ không
toàn bộ những cái tôi có thể biết
khi đó tổng tài sản quay lại bằng không
Rồi đúng
ạ Bây giờ là xử lý Insert vào như này
em sợ mày tốt Bà xã lên không ạ Đây mình
đổi và mỗi sản phẩm từ kho hai sang kho
thứ nhất thì xem thế nào đông ạ update
sản phẩm
xét à
mở mã khóa
bằng 1
a sặc nhà Ông thấy là
ở đây là cốt để mà mình cả
I Insert Delete cả update cùng một chỗ
và đặt tên chữ câu nó là cập nhật sản
phẩm
khi nó thấy nhanh không ạ
Tại sao hôm trước mình là tốt công tạo
Nó tận ba cái chi cơ làm gì đây đây là
gộp đấy Đây là của Google
à tiện vết đỏ đi
đi bụi quái thì tôi mới Chỉ ông mày cái
đấy buổi đầu chị béo mấy cái đấy nếu
mạng choáng
Okay tiếp theo nhé ạ
Sau khi xóa kho thì kiểm tra sản phẩm có
tồn tại không Nếu không mới được xóa
rõ ra là đêm Nếu có mà nếu không thì tức
là nó sẽ không phải after là nó nó sẽ
chạy ít thôi nó sẽ à nó sẽ ra kiểu thay
thế câu lệnh xóa nóng ạ Mình sẽ kiểm tra
trai dễ thôi câu này dễ
press chi cờ
kiểm tra xóa kho cả on all
It is part of a letter
and blog
phải thì bây giờ trong thời điểm này
mình sẽ nếu mà làm hai cậu đơn giản như
thủ công như mọi khi là mình sẽ kiểm tra
theo từng kho một đúng không ạ ngờ bây
giờ mình mà làm nâng cao một tí là ra sự
Xóa tất cả kho ngoại mình chị sẽ chỉ
phép Xóa những cái kho nào mà không có
sản phẩm từ ngọn Thay vì mình làm thủ
công nông dân hội trước đó là mình sẽ
tạo biến rồi kiểm tra
thì chị sẽ chỉ kiểm tra được một kho
thôi nghĩa là que nếu mà các bạn mà chạy
câu lệnh là Delete for kho
Where mã bằng một nha trở lại đâm chị
khoảng Xóa một kho rồi ông ạ thì các bạn
ở đây các bạn chỉ cần kiểm tra đúng theo
từng kho từng khó thôi đúng ạ Còn nếu mà
các bạn Delete from kho Ừ thế này là các
bạn xóa nhiều kho cùng lúc thì cái đoạn
này nó sẽ phức tạp hơn ông ngoại như
mình ở thương ấy nói đó là kệ kể làm
được mà cập nhật nhiều bạn ghi cùng một
lúc nó khó hơn không ạ thì cái vụ này
thì ra vẫn làm được là tiên là mình cứ
đi made from to như thế này thôi và
Where mã nhấn màu của em à theo kiểu lại
nằm trong danh sách theo kiểu là
select
mã for kho forpatec như thế này
Ừ thì nó vẫn là xóa nó vẫn là xóa
Ừ nhưng mà bây giờ mình sẽ thêm điều
kiện nữa Where Mã
ờ ờ
a
noose tin
snacks mã kho
Ford
sản phẩm
như thế này
tin tức là sao mẹ lấy tất cả các
a mã kho của sản phẩm xong ngồi không
nằm trong danh sách này không ạ
Anh nói như thế này cú pháp nó sẽ như
thế này
thì đầu tiên mình cũng vẫn phải lấy mã
nằm trong danh sách mà mình muốn xóa
nóng lại chứ không phải là xóa toàn bộ
những cái kho không không không chứa sản
phẩm nào là xóa không phải như thế đúng
ạ
chú chó nó sẽ đặt câu này để lấy ra mã
của kho
à mà không có sản phẩm nào đúng không ạ
một câu này là xóa
xe tải chạy thử nhé
ở đây phạm con này
ông salad lạnh bạn thấy được da trắng
xóa kho là cả đúng vọng chẳng có ở đâu
có cọ kho thứ hai bị xóa mất rồi bị mới
cập nhật lại đúng rồi mình mới cần nhớ
lại cho kho thứ hai không có sản phẩm
nào đó thế xong không ạ Delete phone
call nhưng mà hiển nhiên nó không nó
không xóa cái thằng kho mà mà có sản
phẩm
em còn nếu mà thư da làm làm cái này chỉ
cho các bạn biết qua về các câu truy vấn
Còn nếu mà để làm ngon hơn nữa cả hiển
thị thông báo là kho nào có sản phẩm rồi
nên không được cái xóa nữa Nó còn chút
tạp hơn nữa thì sẽ không không dạy qua
cái đấy đây nhờ các bạn vẫn có thể sẽ
lách được để lấy ra được những kho làm à
thứ hai để tội chị méo luôn nhé
khi nó thức ăn nó dễ thôi selec mã kho
này hả mã này hôm kho Này
Where
Mã nằm trong danh sách này là được
ừ ừ
à à
anh đợi tôi copy đoạn này nhé
- này vào đây tôi sẽ kèm theo một cái
thông báo đó là không xóa được
thì có sản phẩm rồi
nó enter là
thông báo rằng ạ
Không may tôi chữa cho cả mấy ông người
cái thông báo có thư
Anh quay Thọ enter đ
anh bấm nhầm
à à
ở đó Ok chưa
Ừ cái này trong trường hợp này nó sẽ lại
nóng nghĩa làm chị là có sản phẩm trong
kho rồi ông ạ
chị
sẽ chữa được cho mấy ông nhanh về hai
câu rồi câu cuối này
kiểm tra sức chứa tương ứng với tổng số
lượng của sản phẩm
ở cái đoạn này phức tạp hơn bởi vì nó
tổng số lượng nó khác với cái bài hôm
trước bài hôm trước nó nó là cao nó đến
ạ Con Lần này là là mình sẽ còn phải săm
săm cái số lượng với với nhau đúng nhưng
mà thấy có thai mỗi hàm cao này làm sao
mà chạy được thôi
cho nên tôi nghĩ rằng em vẫn đơn giản
vậy nhỉ
Ừ ừ túi nghĩa thật vẫn đơn giản đấy lấy
cốt cũ vừa nãy copy sang là vẫn chạy đấy
sự
thật lấy cúp phốt từ vừa nãy chạy ra mà
vẫn chạy đấy nhà thôi Tôi lười quá trà
sữa đến đây thôi
anh kết cái cái cốt vừa nãy tôi gỗ đổi
sang là chạy đấy ạ
khi tôi còn xóa xử cô đấy rồi Xin lỗi
mày không
anh ạ
a
hotel có khi hôm nay đến hết rồi nhỉ
em cũng một tiếng rưỡi rồi mà không ạ Để
xem tôi xem có câu hỏi thì cần trả lời
không nhé
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay còn chưa trả lời câu hỏi có
thử đấy À đúng rồi bộ trước thì những
tròn có hỏi gì
anh tóc massage it rồi Ở cũng có mạng
thì lại chả có gì chia sẻ cả bql này nó
hơi nhạt nhẽo tí tôi chia sẻ hết sư bên
cái bên web rồi thì bên này tôi không gì
chia sẻ với ông xin lỗi nếu anh có thể
vào xem mày cái buổi học web nữa mới ông
xem cuối video tôi sẽ chia sẻ một vài
cái nhá
hôm Mạnh ví dặm dài thôi tạm nghỉ nhé
Thế mà chuẩn bị cho buổi sau buổi sau
tôi sẽ không lo chim nữa mà buổi sau tôi
sẽ cộ tôi chắc là sẽ rung rung mà dùng
chế độ quay của nó
thì tôi gửi lên zoom vào trong nhóm ok
Xin chào mào nhé